what is the most effective I don't agree
that body shaming or making someone feel
bad about it
what is the most effective way that
people can lose weight or experience as
a doctor right one of the things eat
less food do more exercise
um
doesn't it really just boil down too
healthy eating less food than your Gully
yeah
do you drink almond milk have been
effective here severe flu do you drink
almond milk I drink plant-based milk you
do you do and do you eat avocados
do you eat avocados
yes a leading study it's an interview
you don't just answer different
questions do you eat Avogadro I eat a
plant-based diet do you eat avocados
yes you do great June
julicados and almonds get made
absolutely you do you realize that in
California every year for six weeks they
fly in billions of bees to create your
almonds and avocados and in that process
several billion bees get murdered
this is a b
right that's a b that that last time I
checked is a living animal billions
get slaughtered okay why can't I
identify as a black lesbian
well firstly I mean I'm serious I'm
serious if I can identify as anything
without any need to prove I'm actually
what that is I I why can't I on
International women's day say I'm Piers
Morgan I'm a black lesbian I think
taking it to a kind of absurd Tomatoes I
think that's talking about with respect
I think that you've already opened the
absurdity door by saying it is Limitless
you can do what you like anyone can say
I'm a woman so I simply ask you why
can't I I mean this point kind of
ridicules trans people to an acceptance
actually I think what you said ridicules
trans people Tommy I mean a look I don't
see why if it's Limitless I can't just
say I'm Piers Morgan I'm a black lesbian
because that is where Limitless
self-identity takes this it means that
male rapists can say they're women and
get into into female prisons it means I
can say I'm a two-spirit penguin or a
black lesbian and why can't I if I said
my pronoun was hottest man and Alive
because that was my genuine pronoun
would you feel obliged to call me that
every day hey hottest man alive no you
wouldn't no so in other words it all
depends who decides what they want to do
isn't that what we're discussing the
fact that I don't have to do that so why
do we have to okay why do we have to
call Sam Smith though because we're
respecting this Choice that's my choice
hottest man alive hottest man alive all
the time that is my choice and I demand
you respect it
well I once identified as a two-spirit
penguin because I was told there are a
hundred genders including astragender
which is an affinity with the Stars and
I was told peers stop being ridiculous I
was like if there are 100 genders I can
be a two-spirit penguin I can now demand
you call me is my pronouns hardest man
alive but you don't want to because you
think that's ridiculous I think Angelina
a bit of fat shaming is a good thing
right I think that when people say to me
you put on a bit of Timber mate it makes
me go back and try and lose a bit of
Timber eat a bit less drink a bit less
get on my pellets on buy off we go right
I I need to have people look at me going
Hey Big Boy lose a bit that's so we're
on it because whenever we mention it on
air as a joke you complain that's it I
do that to you because you're the great
virtue signaling we can't say anything
negative about anybody's body image
everyone's perfect I don't agree I think
a bit of fat shaming is a good thing a
healthy thing what do you think Angelina
I think you're wrong I I don't like
vegans very much I don't think any of
you are very healthy I'm not surprised
by that yeah I think you all look pretty
pasty-faced and unhealthy to me um but
that's your choice what I don't do is I
don't go running into vegan restaurants
and start screaming abuse at you all and
have to be pulled out by people because
you're ruining everyone's fun why do you
do that to meat eaters so the thing is
within years
technology like Precision fermentation
you know old protein is going to produce
the exact same products that you love
right now using a fraction of the land
producing a fraction
it's the exact same product no but I
like eating me fine you know you'll be
in the exact same product
the more the more meat I want to eat
that's absolutely fine it is that's fine
literally it's a bit honestly it's true
the more stuff you do like this I think
I didn't catch that it's true is it
you've said that about three times I
didn't touch it that you like you meet
yes oh oh thanks I didn't get it the
first three times oh you've got me
another one big enough
but where's the salt where's where's it
I don't need any of this gruel yeah to
one side but I will have a bit of steak
just to you don't salt it though you see
all you've achieved is you've made me
want to do this just absolutely
absolutely fine
you go for it
[Music]
well when you claim that you're a
two-spirit penguin yeah you know why I
did that go on because you and I had
this debate about the hundred genders I
made the point if literally you can now
identify in a hundred different ways
your gender including two spirit uh and
all this other stuff then I'm entitled
to identify as a two-spirit penguin in
other words there are no limits and
what's interesting is you want me to
respect all those hundred genders
however ludicrous some of them are but
you have zero respect for my right to
identify myself in any way I see fit so
in other words it's one rule for you you
say Everyone's entitled to say they can
be whatever they want but the moment I
decide that I want to be a history
Spirit penguin you go absolutely nuts I
want to control how I self-identify
that's not that's all about accepting
that women don't come in one particular
size eight shape yeah and I think it's
actually a good thing really yeah yeah
you know putting a 300 pound plus model
is five foot two so to put it in context
she's a hundred pounds heavier than me
and she's uh she's what 11 inches
smaller I just think it's important that
people of all shapes and sizes are
represented in the media just because
women of all shapes and sizes do exist
and it's important that you see yourself
represented but if chess holiday goes to
a doctor he doesn't celebrate her 300
pound size he says to her you're
morbidly obese and you're going to die
if you don't do something drastic about
your weight that's the reality check
behind this ridiculous celebration of
somebody who is morbidly obese when the
stakes were this high
doesn't it make more sense to hear our
story from us
shut up
what do you mean the stakes of this hire
who Do You Think You Are
other than latte munching
imbecile living in luxury in California
while the rest of the world is a
conflict of living crisis moaning and
whining about institution which gave you
the titles on which you now trade
millions of dollars
when you're talking what states are
there other than the massive gigantic
stake you're sorry if I missed something
I thought you've been telling your truth
often a pack of lies from the moment you
abandon this country
well today's new trailer doubles down on
the last trailer and there's more tears
remember that people with Megan watch
showing us how she could cry like that
at the drop of a little teeny tardy
Tiara remember that she could do it like
that
just bear that in mind when you watch it
did you get a one